an actor praises me and gets destroyed
for it president Trump suffers through
Putin fallout and should Americans
defend Montenegro I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
I got to admit I'm kind of in a mood
today and you're going to feel the
benefits or the downsides of that mood
in just a minute but first I want to
remind you that we are taking the Ben
Shapiro show live this August to
audiences in Dallas in Phoenix you
should know we've now sold out of all of
our general admission tickets for Dallas
we're opening up the very last 800 seats
available
we're almost out out sold out of our
event in Phoenix if you haven't gotten
your tickets yet you should get them now
or you could miss out on the event
entirely its daily wired.com slash
events daily wired.com slash events to
get those tickets the events are going
to be great also I don't mind you if you
don't want anyone peeking over your
shoulder when you're on the internet you
don't want anybody gathering your data
you don't want anyone tracking you
online you need a VPN and the people you
should be using for your VPN are
expressvpn expressvpn has easy to use
apps that run seamlessly in the
background of my computer phone and
tablet turning on expressvpn protection
only takes one click expressvpn secures
in a knot and anonymizes your internet
browsing by encrypting your data and
hiding your public IP address and
protecting yourself with expressvpn it
cost less than seven bucks a month
expressvpn is rated the number one VPN
service by TechRadar comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee so if you ever use
public Wi-Fi you want to keep hackers
and spies from seeing your data
expressvpn is the solution if you don't
hand over your online history to your
internet provider or Daniel resellers
expressvpn is indeed your answer so
protect your online activity today I do
I mean there's a lot of folks I know who
are targeting me online that's why I use
Express VPN protect your online activity
today find out how you can get three
months for free and expressvpn comm
slash pen that's Express expr ESS VPN
comm slash ban for three months free
with a one-year package that's
expressvpn comm slash Ben to learn more
go check it out expressvpn comm slash
been for that three months free with the
one-year package okay so one of the
reasons that I'm in a mood today aside
from the fact that I had an allergic
reaction to fish last night and spent
half the night in the hospital aside
from that the reason that I am in a mood
today is because there's a guy who I
thought was a very nice guy named Mark
Duplass mark Duplass you probably
recognized he's faces one of these sort
of face guys from TV or if you see him
walking around on the street go yeah I
recognize that guy from TV but he's not
like a top-line star where you would
know his name he's apparently very big
in some of the indie director circles
like he does a lot of indie director
films and he's you know somewhat
well-known in those circles well
yesterday he tweeted something out and
what he tweeted out was this he tweeted
out fellow liberals if you're interested
at all in cross
in the aisle you should consider
following than Shapiro I don't agree
with him on much but he's a genuine
person who once helped me for no other
reason than to be nice
he doesn't bend the truth his intentions
are good which is much appreciated I
mean it's a nice thing for him to say
right and I'll tell you what the nice
thing that I did for mark Duplass was
and the nice thing I did for marthy
Plaza is he emailed me like a lot of
folks do and he said I'm doing a show
that has to do with a narrative there's
a narrative in there about guns and gun
control and gun use and I wanted to get
a perspective on the right side of the
aisle cuz I don't get to hear that all
that often and I thought that's a nice
thing I'm glad somebody from Hollywood
actually cares enough to want to hear
from people who are pro Second Amendment
folks people who actually care about gun
rights so he came into the office and I
kept it on the down-low because I had
there's a basic rule that I have here we
have we actually do have a fairly large
number of active Hollywood stars who
come into the office who are pretty big
fans of the show or they enjoy what I do
and I have a rule with them which is no
one gets to take pictures basically we
try to keep it on the down-low as much
as possible because Hollywood is a
one-party Stalinist town Hollywood is
the kind of place or if it gets out that
you once took a picture with me they
will crush you right if they find out
that you are friendly with me or once
had dinner we went out to we went out to
lunch or something then they will come
after you with a vengeance and I knew
this right so I knew this for about Mark
Duplass also so Mark Duplass comes in
and we spent probably an hour and a half
just talking over gun rights with him
trying to explain the various points of
view trying to explain where I thought
the flaws were in the pro Second
Amendment position and how do you
counter those where the flaws are in the
in the pro-gun control position how you
counter those I tried to be sort of as
honest about the about the argument as I
possibly could and then we shook hands
and he took off and I said if you need
any other context you need anybody who
you need to talk to on either side of
the aisle I know some folks on both
sides of the aisle who have different
opinions on this issue I'm happy to
facilitate I'm glad that you're actually
trying to take into account views that
may not be your own on this issue all
right very nice everything's fine and
then I didn't ask him to do anything so
I literally have not spoken with him
since this day which was what maybe a
couple of months ago guys there's a
couple of months ago and so he so he
leaves and then he tweets that out right
that very nice thing and that's and
that's fine and then he gets ratioed so
being ratioed on twitter is where you
get more comments than retweets on the
message more comments than likes on the
message people on the left start
bringing up tweets out of context from
10 years ago they start picking up
columns I wrote when I was 19 that I did
someone when I was 27 and they start
trying to
show him that the person who had just
endorsed as a genuine fellow is actually
an evil racist sexist bigot an evil
terrible terrible person and they start
ray showing him right they start they
start targeting me it targeting him for
saying a nice thing about me and
remember that original sweet didn't say
he endorses my political point of view
it doesn't say that he agrees with
nearly anything that I have to say it
just says that I'm a nice genuine person
that's it okay which is really really
innocuous stuff but no one expects the
Spanish Inquisition and so they showed
up and they started going after mark and
mark predictably enough to lead it this
way which is his prerogative
that's his probably I didn't ask him to
tweet it I didn't ask him to delete it
that's all fine and dandy and so I
texted him and I just said listen dude I
understand you're in Hollywood I get why
you felt you had to delete the tweet you
know you're I'm no hard feelings like I
totally totally get it it happens in
Hollywood all the time I appreciate the
original sentiment to this week okay
this morning
mark Duplass puts out an actual apology
for his original tweet so after all of
this happens he actually apologizes for
the original tweet and not only does he
apologize
he now suggests that I in fact endorse
hatred racism homophobia xenophobia or
another form of intolerance here's
here's his entire response quote so
that's what was a disaster on many
levels a disaster a disaster I mean like
like like a tsunami or an earthquake
that tweet was a disaster tweeting that
I was a nice guy who is genuine and I
tried to be honest about the issues that
was a disaster on many levels not just
one level many levels like all the way
down to Dante seventh circle of hell
it's a disaster on every level
he says so that's what it was a disaster
on many levels I want to be clear that I
in no way endorsed hatred racism
homophobia xenophobia or any other such
form of intolerance right because
neither do I like so and then he says my
goal has always been to spread unity
understanding and kindness but I'm going
to make mistakes along the way sometimes
I move too quickly when I get excited or
failed to do enough research or I don't
communicate myself clearly I'm really
sorry I now understand that I need to be
more diligent and careful I'm working on
that
but I do believe deeply and bipartisan
understanding and I will continue to do
my best to promote peace and decency in
this world right now that said I hear
you and I want to say thank you to those
who reached out with constructive
criticism I've genuinely learned so much
and wish everyone all the best he signs
it with his name mark Duplass okay again
free country you can say what you want
I'm not even gonna go into critiquing
whether I think that he did the
right thing here because I think that
it's obvious from what I'm saying that I
think that this is a mistake a strategic
mistake
that if you're trying to reach across
the aisle and you get criticism for
reaching across the aisle
maybe it's the people doing the
critiquing who are the problem maybe
it's not you maybe mark Duplass wasn't
wrong to send that tweet maybe it's all
the people who decided that any attempt
to reach across the aisle was wrong and
let's be clear about something this has
almost nothing to do with me
mark Duplass could have tweeted this
about guy Benson he couldn't sweeted
this about Charles Krauthammer he
couldn't tweeted this about Ann Coulter
he could've tweeted this about any
person on the right any person it would
not matter
he couldn't sweeted this about any
friend probably half the left he
could've tweeted this about and there
was a group of people the this SJW mob
that exists on twitter solely to cudgel
people into line and those are the
people who operate on Hollywood by the
way a lot of those folks are people who
are living in these these massive
mansions off of Sunset Boulevard and
decrying capitalism I promise it wasn't
just the Twitter it wasn't just the
people on Twitter the randos on Twitter
who spend all of their days in their
mommy's basement and are tweeting out
nasty things about me to mark Duplass I
promise you what happened is that his
wife probably came to him and said I got
calls from my friends his brother of I
guess his business partner probably came
to him and said listen we're getting
blowback for this other directors with
whom his friends I'm sure came out and
said why would you possibly have done
this my favorite along these lines by
the way was Tom Arnold
so Tom Arnold to be clear is another
person we've been nice to here at this
office Tom Arnold's came in and actually
did a show with Michael moles and we
were kind enough to let him in with his
camera crew into the office and here's
what he tweeted out now remember I said
nothing publicly about anything Duplass
said here nothing until he actually
until he actually put out that statement
at which point I just said you know it's
sad that this is what the discourse has
come to here's what Tom Arnold a crazy
person tweeted this morning ben shapiro
five-foot-two and sounds prepubescent
but technically a man so for purposes of
brawl and all the kicks headed toward
his teeth and face he shall be deemed
all man and this is after Tom Arnold had
suggested how dare I exist because Mark
Duplass got in trouble for having texted
or tweeted something about me so that's
Tom Arnold right there I'm sure that a
lot of Mark's friends were coming after
him for all of us honestly I feel bad
from her I feel bad for mark because
mark I think was originally trying to do
the right thing and I think that
Hollywood does not allow you to do the
right thing
Hollywood has a vested interest in
making sure that everyone who disagrees
with them in any small minut
is portrayed as the worst person on
earth I don't want to say this is why
you got Trump but this is one of the
reasons that they got from when you lump
everybody together when you say that
everybody who disagrees with you is a
racist sexist homophobic bitter clinger
who just wants guns in God when you say
that that's what those people are and
you cannot even speak to them how dare
you try to have an honest conversation
with one of them and then this is the
predictable result which is that you can
bully anybody with just a few tweets and
unfortunately I think this has become
endemic it's become endemic you know
there's a lot of talk these days about
the so called intellectual dark web so
for folks you don't know what the
intellectual dark web is it's this group
of people who are right and left I
believe I'm the only registered
Republican on the list who have
conversations with each other about a
wide variety of issues you've seen some
members of the IDW appear on my Sunday
special so this would be people like Sam
Harris with whom I disagree about
everything and people like Eric
Weinstein who's gonna be on on Sunday
right so it's a bunch of eric is a
Democrat he's never voted Republican Sam
is a Democrat he's never voted
Republican right it's people ranging
from Jordan Peterson to Dave Rubin to
Christina Hoff Sommers I believe I'm the
only registered Republican on that list
and the reason that exists the reason
this IDW exists is because it's a bunch
of people who are honestly trying to
reach answers by having conversations
with one another and we don't want to
engage with the worst versions of the
arguments we're not interested in
engaging with the stupidest version the
other side has to present and we're not
interested in the sort of mudslinging
that goes on on Twitter and this has all
become very very popular the reason that
he's become popular the reason it is
important is because the left has become
so deeply intolerant of anything
remotely resembling an honest
conversation because let me be clear
about this if Mark had come into this
office and Mark had filmed us talking
for an hour and a half in cordial
fashion he got hit the exact same way he
would you even had to tweet out that
people should follow me on Twitter if
they want an honest conservative take he
wouldn't even had to do that all the way
he would have had to do is set foot in
the studio and treat me like a human
being that would have been enough to
earn the ire of the left that would have
been enough how do I know
because when Bill Maher had me on his
show and treated me like a human being
and by the way it was pretty far left
when he talked about Trump and Russia he
got blowback from the left for even
having me on because that's how this
works now the goal here is to shut that
Overton Window tight to make sure that
no one who exists outside that Overton
Window that that area of a authentic
decent discourse in
outside that that area of accepted
opinion that area of accepted left-wing
opinion is allowed to talk or have a
conversation with one another if you had
a problem with something I said in the
past I have a great solution for this
why you asked me about it because it
turns out that if you did half a second
of research you would realize that
people change their opinions over time
the people make mistakes you might
realize that your misconstruing
something someone said normally that's
happening on purpose instead it's a lot
easier to run for the safe space and
pretend that everyone who is who
disagrees with you and that's the real
problem here is that in the end I'm sure
mark and I disagree on all these issues
and that really is the problem because
if I were on the Left I don't think that
mark number one would've gotten the
blowback and number two I doubt that he
would have apologized because Hollywood
doesn't care now you can like you can be
friends with Tom Arnold right you can
you can openly endorsed Tom Arnold who's
in a legit crazy person and that's
totally fine but if you endorse anybody
who disagrees with you then you must be
taken out to the woodshed and cane okay
I have a little bit more on this first I
want to talk about weight loss so
everything that we have been talking
about weight loss is actually making us
unhealthy the supplements that we
actually use when we are losing weight
very often are packed with sugar and
artificial ingredients and processed
foods well if you're looking for healthy
supplements that are packed with
nutrients that promote weight loss you
need to look at 310 nutrition 310
nutrition is the brand you can help to
try that you can trust to help you lose
weight and live out a healthy lifestyle
with the help of a variety of terrific
products 310 nutrition is the maker of
the 310 meal replacement shake that's
packed with top-quality plant-based
proteins vitamins minerals superfoods
probiotics 310 lemonade and hid water
enhancer is great for people who don't
like to drink water because water than
things like anything instead 310
lemonade helps make water taste better
there bunch people in the office I know
sandy has been using 3:10 nutrition she
says it's just awesome and that all of
the food tastes great and has been in
real aid in weight loss join the 310
nutrition community for free by going to
310 family com
that's 310 family calm and in addition
to the great community of people you'll
be joining joining 310 nutrition is
offering my listeners there 310 starter
nutrition kit for just 14 bucks he'll
receive an assortment of 310 meal
replacement shakes a meal plan ebook
ecard gift card and many other products
don't miss out on the great offer and
join the free community joining 310
nutrition is a great way to engage with
thousands of like-minded individuals who
are trying to lose weight and become
healthier and doing it in the healthiest
possible way check it out 310 family com
that's 3 100
family calm 3/10 family calm great
products in their product and and you'll
really enjoy it and it'll it'll help you
be a healthier a healthier human being
ok so here is the real question is it
good for the left to continually came to
this mob my answer is it is not good for
the left it's probably good for the
right that the let's continually came to
this mob here's the truth and pure
partisan breakdown the more the left
caves to its most extreme radicals and
says we're not gonna have a conversation
across the other side of the aisle the
more they are likely to engage in an
echo chamber where they move further and
further and further to the left and that
is further and further and further away
from the American people the way that
you end up in an intersectional bubble
of your own making or you're not allowed
to talk about politics unless you have
the right skin color or the right
background or the right ethnicity the
way you end up in that bubble is by
excising everyone who doesn't count in
your little group and again though this
is the way that it works in Hollywood
Hollywood morality has now been expanded
out across America but it is
particularly predominant in Hollywood
you know my business partner Jeremy
boring he was the executive director of
the of the least secret secret
organization in history of manners on
the front page of the New York Times
that organization was called Friends of
am friends of the ables a group of
literally thousands thousands upon
thousands of Hollywood conservatives
grips writers producers actors directors
and they all had to be part of a secret
group because they know what kind of
blowback you face for even saying that
you voted for george w bush or he didn't
oppose the war in iraq or he thought
about voting for Donald Trump right that
kind of stuff gets you excised in
Hollywood gets you destroyed I wrote an
entire book on this red book I wrote a
book called primetime propaganda all
about leftist bias in Hollywood in which
a bunch of top name Hollywood producers
admitted openly to me on tape that they
discriminated against conservatives in
their work so I understand what Mark
Duplass was going up against here I
understand it better than anybody I
literally wrote the book on it I've only
four hundred page book on it I get it
all I can say is that that mentality has
now extended out across America
unfortunately think it exists for some
folks on the right side of the aisle as
well I think there's a small sliver of
the right that says that if you talk
with somebody across the aisle then that
is that is to be condemned in the worst
possible fashion all right but it's
certainly not as extreme it is a
mainstream thing on the left now it's a
mainstream that you you cannot find a
single conservative outsider maybe David
Frum who's no longer conservative you
can't find a single conservative the
left thinks it's okay to talk to the
only ones the light you talk to our max
boot and David from because max boot has
decided you should vote Democrat and so
there's David from
and maybe Jorge will now because Jorge
will says you should vote Democrat
there's not a single person in America
who says vote Republican that the left
would not have attacked with equal vigor
over over an actor saying that you maybe
ought to follow my stuff it really is
amazing and the lack of knowledge is
pretty amazing to James Gunn who's the
director of guardians of the galaxy and
guardians of the galaxy's who got into
the act he said that it was wrong that
Duplass had been attacked and then he
said but I would tell I would never tell
anyone to follow Ben Shapiro I wouldn't
tell his own mother to follow him he's a
bleep hole it's like you don't know
anything about me too but I understand
you have two virtue signal for your
friends so you feel better at the
cocktail parties okay so this is the way
the left has decided to operate
unfortunately it is having some broader
implications for not governmental
oriented free speech but for the
attitude of free speech that we have in
the country so the latest example of
this is Mark Zuckerberg is now under
serious fire because he has defended the
rights of Facebook users to publish
Holocaust denial posts he said he didn't
think that they're intentionally getting
it wrong this is according the Guardian
which means too biased source to the
left in an interview with recode
published on Wednesday the CEO also
explained Facebook's decision to allow
the far-right conspiracy theory website
Infowars to continue using the platform
saying the social network would quote
try to reduce the distribution of that
content but would not censor the page
the Zuckerberg scons came the same day
Facebook announced a new policy pledging
to remove misinformation used to incite
physical harm and people jumped all over
zonker Berg for this now
am ia Infowars fan if you didn't get
from my myriad impersonations of Alex
Jones turning a frog bird the answer is
no I am NOT an info Wars fan and Alex
Jones is not my fan last time he talked
about me on his show I believe he said
that Satan should get behind him and
then there's actually an atheist sent to
convert the Christians congratulations
guys you've been suckered but when all
of this happened here's my view Facebook
is a platform Facebook is not actually a
publisher and that means that it's not
Facebook's job to prevent any sort of
speech except for speech that is open
incitement to violence but the left
believes that anything bad ought to be
shut down now they actually believe that
when it comes to publishers like
Facebook they should be shut down by the
government the government should
actually intervene and violate free
speech laws and shut down hate speech
right this is what the Left believes but
even in normal everyday conversation the
idea is that stuff that's not nearly as
Extreme as Infowars or nearly as Extreme
as Holocaust oh now that stuff should
not be allowed into the public debate
here's the thing I think
three categories their speech that is
allowed which i think is nearly
everything there is speech that is good
which i think is not very much and then
their speech that is reasonable to
debate with and that's a broader group
right so you have the smallest circle
which is the speech I agree with them
like and then there's the broader circle
which is speech that I don't agree with
don't necessarily like it all that much
but I think is worthy of engagement and
then there's this broad broad broad
circle which is speech that should be
allowed some of which i think is just
vile and disgusting okay for the left
what the left has done is they have now
collapsed a couple of these circles into
themselves so that first circle which is
stuff that I like it's in that I agree
with that circle has become the second
circle stuff that I'm willing to engage
with right the only stuff they're
willing to engage with is stuff they
agree with if you disagree with somebody
you're not allowed to have a
conversation about it because that just
shows that they're wrong and secretly
secretly their racist sexist bigoted
homophobes and we have the proof because
we have old tweets ten years ago taken
out of context deliberately we have the
proof this is what the left is
attempting to do right now and it
creates this sense of frustration on the
right it creates a sense like well if
anybody is willing to shatter this
entire matrix that has been created by
the left with regard to speech go do it
Trump's popularity is very much tied to
this Trump's popularity has tied to the
idea that the dude takes a hammer to the
politically correct matrix now I've said
many times I don't know he's like how he
does it I think the president Trump says
things that are not just politically
incorrect but that are flat-out wrong I
think that happens but he drive on the
right to listen to President Trump when
he when he says outrageous things is
driven by the fact that the left has
ruled everything into the outrageous
category every single thing is now in
the outrageous category so I and
President Trump is Charles Krauthammer
is George well they're all the same
according to the left now all these
people are the same now if you have any
brains or you take half a moment of
self-reflection you realize there's a
pretty wide diversity of viewpoints
between all of the people that I just
mentioned but if you're on the Left then
all these people must be cast into the
outer darkness the left has basically
become little boy in the twilight of
Twilight Zone episode who wishes people
into the corn and everybody who wants to
have a reasonable conversation they're
just sitting in the room with the little
boy hoping that he doesn't wish them
into the corn - right because if they
get wished into the corner and they have
to hang out with all those deplorable
'he's so eventually what something's
going to happen right and what's
happened here is that the left being
this little boy who wishes people into
the cornfield you know if you offend him
too much he wishes people into the
cornfield but left being
that that little boy eventually that
little boy will be the only one left in
the town and that little boy can't take
care of himself that little boy is not
capable of feeding himself or governing
or having a conversation that a little
boy is capable of nothing the tyrannical
nature of the left with regard to having
decent conversation is is utterly
asinine I'm willing to converse with
pretty much everyone
outside of you know open Holocaust
deniers and even those people I don't
think ought to be banned I don't think
it should be laws against them I just am
not willing to to listen to that point
of view because I think it's so
obviously a factual but there plenty of
people on the left I talked to on a
frequent basis and you know what polls
show polls show the Conservatives talk
to people on the Left far more than the
leftist talk to conservatives far far
more because it turns out that
conservatives are willing to actually
engage in argument discussion and people
on the Left believe that they are so
morally righteous because politics is
their religion that all the blasphemers
must be burned at the stake and anyone
who harbors the blasphemers like Mark
applause those people must also be
burned at the stake as well just really
really delightful folks really
delightful folks okay so in just a
second I want to get to President Trump
who continues to get himself in hot
water over Vladimir Putin and Russia
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so you didn't sleep well last
night I know you didn't right you're
sitting there right now and your eyes
are closing and you're thinking oh god
I'm so glad I have this podcast to
listen to otherwise my head would hit
this keyboard where I am at work well
that is why you need helix sleep because
working with the world's leading sleep
experts helix sleep has developed the
mattress that is customized to your
specific height weight and sleep
preferences so you can have the best
sleep of your life at an unbeatable
price so here's how it works go to helix
sleep calm fill out there two minutes
sleep quiz they'll design your custom
mattress they can even customize each
side for you and a partner in 2018 helix
sleep has taken customized sleep to the
next level with the helix pillow the
Omni pillows are fully adjustable so you
can achieve perfect comfort regardless
of sleep position or body type helix
sleep has thousands of five-star reviews
plus you get a hundred nights to try
them out personally I was so impressed
with my helix sleep mattress that I
actually gave a gift to my sister for
her wedding I give this mattress to my
sister as a wedding present she was able
to go through the process on the website
and get a customized mattress that
worked for her and for her husband and
she's just really I mean she's she's so
excited to have the right I'll be honest
with you it wasn't that I have such
great ideas for gifts my sister said I
heard about the helix loop mattress can
you get that for us and that's how we
ended up with the helix sleep mattress
it's really great helix leap comm slash
spending it up to 125 bucks toward your
mattress order that's helix sleep comm
slash Ben
up to 125 bucks toward that mattress
order again helix sleep comm at /bin
okay so meanwhile more how about
breaking up breaking out over President
Trump and his meeting with Vladimir
Putin President Trump tweeted this
morning that he thinks that there should
be a second meeting with Vladimir Putin
which made his entire national security
team shudder to their core the polls
showed that Republicans are pretty much
okay with Trump's meeting with Putin
which is not a real surprise because
Republicans take every poll question on
President Trump as a referendum on Trump
as a whole so if you ask Republicans
President Trump took a dump on the front
lawn of the White House
approve or disapprove most Republicans
see that as the as the media attempting
to get Trump and they will say a proof
really like six and ten Republicans
seven in ten Republicans they always see
poll questions as an attempt to paint
Trump in a bad light and say that they
will defend him no matter what but and
that's not unique to Republicans this
happens to Democrats too
Jimmy Kimmel does this routine where he
will actually go out and ask people
about particular policies that were
Trump policies that are not Obama
policies but he'll say that they were
Obama policies and Democrats will
suddenly embrace the policy so this is
just something people do as a general
rule people tend to fall toward
confirmation bias
and they tend to fall toward this kind
of tribal siding with particular
political figures but suffice it to say
Trump's move on Monday with Russia was
not popular across the country 60% of
Americans did not like his press
conference with Vladimir Putin and now
there's a new report out from the New
York Times that is not particularly good
for the President of the United States
because Trump has basically been
suggesting for a while that he doesn't
believe his intelligence community when
it comes to their assessment all 17
intelligence agencies that the Russians
were trying to monkey with our with our
election and through through information
breaches and hacks and release of that
information Trump
apparently according to the New York
Times was told two weeks before his
inauguration that there was classified
intelligence highly classified
intelligence indicating that Putin had
personally ordered complex cyber attacks
to sway the 2016 American election the
evidence included texts and emails from
Russian military officers and
information gleaned from a top-secret
source close to mr. Putin who described
to the CIA how the Kremlin decided to
execute its campaign of hacking and
disinformation mr. Trump's gonna
grudgingly convinced according to
several people who attend in the
intelligence briefing but ever since mr.
Trump has tried to cloud the very clear
findings that he received on January 6
2017 which his own intelligence leaders
have unanimously endorsed so as that
President Trump not believing his own
intelligence
I don't think so I think that's
President Trump looking at the data and
not liking the data and so the data
becomes false because he doesn't like it
president Trump has a has an unfortunate
tendency to do that so for example
yesterday he was asked at the end of a
press conference that was happening in
one of the cabinet rooms he was asked
whether Russia is still attempting to
interfere in our political system and
here was his answer well probably as
well as anybody has ever done with
Russia okay so he went on to talk about
all the harsh measures he's taken
against Russia and a lot of that is true
when he says no when he says no now the
White House says he wasn't using no to
something else people in the room say
that's not true assume for a second that
he said no that Russia was not monkeying
with the who is not monkeying now at the
election that obviously is counter what
his intelligence officials are saying as
in right now so here's FBI director
Chris Rea explaining no actually the
Russians are sort of attempting to medal
the intelligence community's assessment
has not changed my view has not changed
which is that Russia attempted to
interfere with the last election and
that it continues to engage in malign
influence operations to this day okay
and that of course is is I think the the
general consensus of the intelligence
community DNI coats the Director of
National Intelligence Stan Coates he
said three days before Trump said that
Russia wasn't monkeying with us that the
lights are now blinking red when it
comes to cyber security threats directly
from Russia he was in the months prior
to September 2001 when according to then
CIA director George Tenet the system was
blinking red and here we are two decade
nearly two decades later and I'm here to
say the warning lights are breeki
blinking red okay so the White House
tried to walk this back a little bit
Sarah Huckabee Sanders came out she said
Trump wasn't denying Russian
interference that's fine you know I'm
glad that she said that the president
Trump himself on CBS says that he holds
Putin directly responsible for the
meddling this is the sort of language
that you need consistently from the
presidents of the United States this is
good Trump right we've seen some bad
Trump here's some good Trump on CBS
Evening News last night
you haven't condemned Putin specifically
do you hold him personally responsible
well I would because he's in charge of
the country just
like I consider myself to be responsible
for things that happen in this country
so certainly as the leader of a country
you would have to hold him responsible
yes
okay so that is exactly the right answer
and I would hope the president Trump
would continue to say that over and over
and over because the reality is that
Putin according to the intelligence
community and they have better
information than I do or you do right is
saying that the Russians were attempting
to interfere in the election not
necessarily to make Trump win per se but
to ensure that President Trump and
Hillary Clinton were locked in this in
this acrimonious debate over over Russia
specifically I think that's what Putin
wants Putin wants us yelling at each
other and he's sure got it
yeah if President Trump president Trump
can can I think a lot of this again it's
just an ego problem I think that if
President Trump could just say listen I
didn't collude with Russia Russia did
attempt to intervene in the election
there's no evidence that that swung the
election finale that the the outcome of
the election was not based on Russian
interference but we don't want Russia
screwing with us if he had said that I'm
on board that's exactly right that's
exactly right from all the evidence that
I can see instead he continues to signal
and his administration continues to
signal confusion over what are fairly
clear issues right that are only a
couple of issues here did he collude yes
or no the answer according to Trump and
I believe this is no did Russia
interfere in the election the answer
according to all of our intelligence
agencies is yes one and two don't have
to be the same thing right you can say
no to collusion and yes to interfere
it's not the same thing and question
three did that interference actually
swing the election of Trump and you can
say I don't see the evidence for that
that's fine with me as well I think that
Hillary Clinton lost that election end
of story okay so all of this is actually
quite simple but the administration
seems to be struggling over it because
Trump is at war with himself his head is
saying all the things that I'm telling
you right now
and his heart is saying I don't like
anything the intelligence community
tells me so I'm just going to reject all
of it outright well this ends up putting
the administration itself in a very odd
and kind of ugly position so Sarah
Huckabee Sanders White House press
secretary yesterday she specifically
asked about an offer that Vladimir Putin
made to to Donald Trump in Helsinki and
that offer was Putin had said where he
said we're happy to bring Americans like
Bob Muller over to Russia to watch us
investigate all of these supposed
Russian bad actors but in return we want
you to work on the arrest and in
shipment to Russia of Michael McFaul the
former US ambassador to Russia as well
as Bill Browder a British citizen who is
largely response
for the passing of Magnitsky axe which
is essentially a set of sanctions that
was put in place in 2012
okay now the normal answer that is no we
have no evidence these people broke the
law if you want to provide evidence
these people broke the law and have
Interpol arrest them you can try that
they've tried it with Bill Browder in
Spain most most recently it failed he
was released but the even-even
countenancing the idea that we are going
to essentially trade American citizens
like Michael McFaul who had the temerity
to pass a sanctions bill against Russia
for like basically we're gonna take a
political prisoner ship into Russia to
Putin and in exchange we are going to
receive back these 12 hackers it's it's
asinine but Sarah Huckabee Sanders
couldn't quite disown it yesterday
here's what it looked like was gonna
meet with his team and we'll let you
know when we have an announcement on
that second is that a topic that came up
in their conversation didn't raise this
with the president there was some
conversation about it but there wasn't a
commitment made on behalf of the United
States and the president will work with
his team and will let you know if
there's and they're now stood on that
front okay that is the wrong answer the
right answer is
there was discussion and Trump laughed
at it right because we're not gonna
start arresting American citizens and
sending them to Russia just cuz Vladimir
Putin wants to quote unquote make an
offer and that's that's an absurdity
it's an absurdity now do I think that
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is actually going
to be interested in shipping bill
Browder and Michael McFaul
back to Russia no I don't think that at
all so I think Trump is either no I
think what happened here is there's a
disconnect at the White House and this
is a real problem with how Trump governs
that disconnect is pretty simple the
disconnect is that President Trump
usually comes to the right conclusion
but only on his own if he feels that
people are pushing him in a particular
direction he tends to push back against
them so the normal response by any press
secretary even not having asked the
president would have been no of course
he wouldn't consider such a thing
knowing that they have the faith of the
president and that the president would
never consider such a thing for Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and other people in the
White House I think there's a tendency
to say we'll consider it because they
figure okay then they'll go back the
last Trump Trump will say no and then
they'll come back the next day and
they'll say of course we're not going to
do any of that right I think this is
actually more of a personality issue
than an issues issue but it does grant a
certain amount of aid to to Putin in his
attempt to portray Trump as a lack of
his and that's what Putin wants more
than anything makes perfect sense that
ambassador McFaul under Obama again not
a big fan of ambassador McFaul but he's
not wrong here he says that he is
flabbergasted that the White House
defend him against Putin I was totally
flabbergasted by was that the White
House would not defend me I'm an
American citizen I worked for the
government for five years and it would
have been so easy to bat it back okay
and that's that's right I mean and they
should ban it back again this is not a
time for uncertainty this is a time for
looking strong in the face of Vladimir
Putin's aggression otherwise you might
get more Vladimir Putin aggression talk
a little bit more about that in just a
second first I want to tell you about a
target Pro so according to Gallup about
42 percent of all American households
have a firearm with about three and five
receiving receiving formal firearms
training which means that a very small
percentage of Americans actually even
know how to use their firearm properly
and even smaller percentage regularly
practice with the weapon they would use
in a self-defense situation because it's
too expensive or you live too far from
the gun range you're busy the ammos
listen I get all of that but that's why
there's a high target Pro there
revolutionising home firearm training
it's really fun I target use your actual
gun so you can become proficient with
the firearm you're actually going to use
in real life you can use your smartphone
that propietario layer and their
proprietary app uses a laser in place of
the bullet and it'll detect exactly
where your shots are landing it's really
cool you set it up and put this little
bullet like device in the chamber of the
gun and then you aim toward a paper
target and you set up your phone in such
a way that it sort of films the target
and the phone picks up where the laser
is going the app picks up where the
laser is going and that shows you how
you score on the on the eye targeting
markets it's pretty awesome you can
practice home defense where it matters
most in your home you can even test
different angles in your house so let's
say that you want to test like how you
would shoot around a corner you can
actually set up the the system so that
it can test that for you you can
maximize your tactical advantage and
most importantly you do it using your
own personal firearm I've used it before
Candace who's our tour manager over here
she uses a target all the time like
she's told me that when she's home with
her husband that basically she'll go
looking for the gun and then she'll
realize that he's out playing with it
with the AI target because he's just
trying to perfect his abilities with it
I I got an AI target for another member
of the production crew over here as well
it's really fantastic right now save ten
percent with the offer code Shapiro when
you purchase the AI target pro system
save money time take your skills to the
next level safely and effectively that's
the letter I target procom
I target procom offer promo code Shapiro
and get ten percent off with that promo
code ship here I'll go check it out
right now okay well we have a lot more
coming up
first you're gonna have to go over to
tailee where calm and subscribe for
$9.99 a month you too can get a
subscription to daily wire when you do
you get the rest of this show live the
rest of the Andrew Klavan in the Andrew
Clavin show live there are some michael
moles show live lots and lots of good
stuff comes to you plus you get to be
part of the mailbag which we'll be doing
tomorrow asking me questions when we
have episodes of the conversation you
get to ask questions i only ask you only
let's be honest about this i'm only
going to answer your question if you pay
me I mean that's basically how this
works
so if you want to be a person who gets
your questions answered and not one of
the sad folks sending in questions that
don't get answered all you have to do is
toss a little money at the Daily wire
guys not that tough 99 bucks a year gets
you the annual subscription including
this the very greatest in beverage
vessels the leftist years hot or cold
tumbler go check it out right now and
make sure also that you subscribe at
youtube and at itunes we have a great
Sunday special coming up it is with my
good friend Eric Weinstein who I like to
talk with because he's across the aisle
and is a Democrat but we can have
conversations because I'm not a jackhole
okay so you so go check that out and and
and subscribe we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
okay so good stuff happening here
justjust all sorts of good stuff
happening here let's let's talk a little
bit about the implications that are
being put forward by some of trumps
bigger defenders right now so some of
trumps bigger defenders are defending
his activity with regard to Russia by
saying that we just need to change
direction I don't like that argument
very much because Bush thought the same
thing and so did Obama the question is
in what direction we move there is an
ideological tendency on the part of some
people on the right toward isolationism
we talked about this a little bit with
regard to Tucker Carlson yesterday so
Tucker double down on it last night
I think Tucker again is a very smart guy
and he's a deeply talented dude for sure
last night he was talking and and he
suggested that we don't really have to
defend Montenegro he stood by his his
criticism of NATO there's no reason for
us to defend Montenegrins we really want
our boys dying in Montenegro membership
in NATO obligates the members to defend
any other member that's attacked so
let's say Montenegro it's joined last
year's attack why should my son go to
Montenegro to defend it from attack why
is that what you're saying I've asked
the same question I understand that that
but that's the way it was set up
presidents are supposed to wonder about
things like that serious countries or to
have debates like that the u.s. has to
defend Montenegro really why is that is
there a good reason let's hear it that's
the conversation we should be having
okay so let's have that conversation is
it should we be defending Montenegro
okay so first of all let's be clear
about what NATO is president Trump
suggested Montenegro could get very
aggressive with the Russians and then
we'd have to jump in on their aggressive
side I said yesterday Montenegro is not
attacking Russia Montenegro is this big
and Russia is this big okay that's not
the thing that's going to happen but
also Russia has nuclear weapons so yeah
good luck with that but beyond that the
NATO Charter does not does not mandate
that we actually get into Wars we're a
member of NATO is the aggressor it's a
defensive pact hey a defensive pact is a
good pact the problem with all of the
pacts that existed in lead-up to World
War one is that those were not defensive
pacts those were actually offensive
pacts it was any any group at any time
could attack any other group and it led
people to believe that there is going to
be a winnable war also the the alliances
that had been formed were relatively
equal the United States is the world
hegemon he combined that with the other
members of NATO and no one can stand up
to that sort of power nobody can stand
up to that sort of power obviously
that's the whole purpose of NATO the
whole purpose of NATO is that
we are stronger together than we would
be apart now do we actually want our
troops in Montenegro of course no-one
wants our troops in Montenegro I don't
want my troops in France I don't wanna I
don't want our troops in France or
Germany or South Korea or anyplace else
I'd prefer that everybody be home and
everything be hunky-dory but our
military exists to protect the safety
and security of Western civilization and
more importantly of the United States
and the way that you make sure that we
never have to put troops in Montenegro
is you don't act weak around dictators
hey there this idea that you could make
exactly the same argument you could make
exactly the same argument do we really
want American troops to die for
Czechoslovakia do we really want
American troops to die for this you date
and land do you really want American
troops to die for for that matter France
or Britain right which which list of
countries I really would like to know
this actually which list of countries
does Tucker Carlson think that it would
be okay
for American troops to fight are there
any and if so why why is likewise France
significantly better than Montenegro for
example why is that why is that deeply
important widespread is French territory
better are the French better people like
why is it the day deserve defense as
opposed to just the entire alliance that
gets together and helps us out after
9/11 remember after 9/11 we invoked the
NATO charter that is the only time the
NATO Charter has ever been invoked the
only time
Montenegro had active duty soldiers in
Afghanistan because we invoke the NATO
charter the whole point here is that no
one wants to defend Montenegro but
you're not gonna have to defend
Montenegro if you say you cross that
line and we bust you up
all right this is this is true in every
set this is basic Reagan foreign policy
peace through strength was the idea not
just that we're going to build up our
military capacity but then if you cross
that line we are going to break you but
if you make this move we will fight you
to the ends of the earth usually the way
the United States gets thrown into
conflict is by not doing that usually
the way the United States gets thrown
into conflict is by acting isolationist
up till the point where an unspoken red
line is crossed and which point we have
to jump into the war and that's exactly
what happened for example with world war
ii where the united states by the time
of world war ii had the 19th largest
military in the world smaller than the
army of the philippines okay and we had
signaled that we were going to be
isolationist and that let our enemies to
become more and more aggressive to the
point where they actually attacked us
and then we had to fight a horrible
bloody war same thing happened in World
War one where the United States
literally pledged not to get into the
war and then was drawn gradually into
the war and lots and lots of people died
if you don't want war make sure that the
other side knows that if you do
we're gonna break them they're gonna
bust him up they're gonna knock out
their teeth that is why we got to defend
Montenegro okay we got to defend
Montenegro so then we never have to
defend Montenegro that is the point okay
now let's talk about some more extremism
by some leaders on the left now it's
always funny
when I talk about extremism on either
political side there are a lot of folks
who suggest well you're just
cherry-picking you're just picking the
worst examples of everybody you're
taking things out of context you're
picking all the worst well not really
keith Ellison is the deputy head of the
DNC he was almost the head of Democratic
National Committee he said yesterday
that if you don't allow people to freely
cross the border for any reason if you
don't allow us you just open up our
borders this creates injustice this is
the direction in which the left moves
when they cut themselves off from the
American people and any debate involving
the American people here's what keith
ellison again Deputy Chair of the DNC
had to say corporations certain people
who get certain rights can go back and
forth across the border seeking out the
lowest wages but people regular people
cannot go back and forth across the
border seeking out the highest wages so
what it creates is an imbalance it
creates an injustice and what it and it
creates the need for something like a
global Marshall Plan a global margin so
we need a global Marshall Plan and we
need to get rid of all of the various
borders that we have so this is a
mainstream position on the left now
kicki Felson is a mainstream actor just
like jeremy corbyn is the mainstream
position on the left in britain
alexandre okay Jie Cortese yes she's the
oh she's she said got her name sort of
the sort of right there I'm really
having trouble at this one she is she is
now the mainstream of left they've moved
far to the left and one of the reasons
they moved fired the left is because
they're no longer having conversations
that are worthwhile the last election
cycle saw Donald Trump say a few things
that I think were credible right he I
think he exaggerated the case but he
said a few things that were basically
true and a lot of people him left
refused to accept them he said that
there is a problem with regard to
radical Islamic terror and he said that
over and over and over radical Islamic
terror then Hillary Clinton would come
out and say there is nothing wrong with
Islam and if she just pulled the
American public what you'd find is that
most Americans don't think that all
Muslims are terrorists most Americans do
think that radical Islamic terror is a
problem but because she was so convinced
that everybody on the right is a Reuben
a hick she decided I can just safely
ignore those people and I can label
everyone in deplorable and it'll be fine
for me the same thing happened with
regard to immigration Trump ran on a
hardline immigration platform probably
the hardest line immigration platform
we've ever seen and Trump won because of
that why not because people actually
agree with every elements of that
hardline immigration platform in fact
polls show people don't even necessarily
grant the wall right but what it does
show is that there is a seething problem
that is bubbling under the surface in
this country with regard to immigration
where people are looking at a legal
immigration they're saying there are a
lot of people coming here and they're
coming here for the benefits and there
are a lot of people who are coming here
who are criminals and there are a lot of
people who are coming here who are just
not being integrated into our culture
and that doesn't mean we're
anti-immigrant it means go to the border
and cross legally it means we have to
vet the people who come into the country
and Trump took that to its ultimate
extreme he basically said illegal
immigrants are disproportionately all of
these things all these bad things which
is not true but it is true that this was
a problem that Americans were seeing and
the left was simply saying Mike keith
Ellison open up all the borders this is
the danger of an echo chamber so when
you rule out viewpoints from the other
side particularly reasonable viewpoints
from the other side because everybody's
a racist sexist picket homophobe all you
end up doing is isolating yourself all
you end up doing is destroying your own
credibility with your own people and
this has become I think the case of the
left this is why the Left keeps winning
the culture and they keep losing the
political wars it's really fascinating
to watch what's happening right now in
the country because if you look at
Hollywood Hollywood continues to move
left left left left left as far left as
they possibly could go and then if you
look at politics politics keeps moving
to the right right Republicans have won
the presidential election they won the
last one two three four congressional
elections they've been in power since
2010 and before that they were in power
from 1994 all the way till 2000 and all
the way till 2006 so they 22 years of
power
sorry 12 years of power and then they've
had an uninterrupted run of eight years
of power in Congress in the Senate the
Republicans have taken back the Senate
they've taken in 12 governors houses
since Obama took office
they've taken 35 state legislators
something like that okay all of that's
happening because the left has so
ensconced itself in this bubble of
happiness and warmth where everyone
agrees with them so the culture where
you're not allowed to talk to people
across the aisle that culture has
created this bubble mentality among
leftist politicians and that's why
they're losing elections so I think it's
safe to say
Hollywood in DC which are very much
interconnected on the Democratic side of
the aisle they've created the
self-reinforcing radicalism that is
causing the left to lose elections it's
also destroying the country as a whole
because we can't have good conversations
with one another but it is certainly
causing the left to become more and more
and more radical which is a serious
serious problem for the future of the
country okay so let's get to some things
I like and then some things that I hate
so things that I like today there's a
great sports book by a guy named Carlo
Rotella it's called cut time Carlo
Rotella is an Ivy Leaguer who just got
into boxing and followed it around for a
while
it's called cut time and education at
the fights about halfway through it it's
really fun if you're into boxing if
you're into MMA if you're into any sort
of sports at all it's really great
writing he followed around Larry Holmes
who's one of the great sort of unsung
heavyweight champions of all time and
talked to him he talked to various
people who are losers and fights boxing
books at that I've recommend a bunch of
boxing books on the show before I think
boxing has an innate drama to it that
lends itself really well to literature
this of course is nonfiction but it's
worth checking out it was I think on the
Sports Illustrated 2003 list of best
books it's one of the better sports
books I've read in a very long time go
check it out cut time and education at
the fights by Carlo rotella okay other
things that I like so this was pretty
hilarious Sacha Baron Cohen has been
going around trying to Punk people he's
been going around trying to do the
Ashton Kutcher he dresses up in these
weird costumes he dressed up is like a
Mossad agent well now he decided he was
going to dress up as a hick and go into
a gun shop and things did not go well
for him here's what it sounded like
[Music]
you're watching the moments employees of
a Riverside gun store say they caught
actor Sacha Baron Cohen coming to their
shop in disguise and under false
pretense nobody done like that talking
like that and I just kept looking at the
guy and I was like you're Borat
as soon as I said that his I just looked
at me like and he did Abby turned right
out the door
well good good and everyone should be on
their guard because they're Borat's
Borat's everywhere so you know you sort
of have to assume now that everything
you ever said will be recorded that's
just the way that everything works now
but good for that gun shop owner the
only thing that would have been even
better is if he had pranked Borat right
like he'd recognized that it was Borat
instead of tossing out of the shop
he'd basically offered to sell him like
a zucchini gun or hehe he made up
different types of guns and shown how
ignorant a Sacha Baron Cohen is actually
about guns I think he actually said to
him you know in the back I have a
grenade launcher that attaches to a
pistol you know are you would you like
to buy that and then just and and Sacha
Baron Cohen probably would've aired that
because nobody at Showtime nobody
Showtime knows a damn thing about guns
you should have said I what do you want
your chainsaw adapter for your for your
shotgun it would've been really great
but that was pretty good in of itself
basically telling your boar I get the
hell out of here well done dude well
done random gun shop owner I appreciate
it okay quick thing that I hate so the
show today has been chock-full of things
I hate but here's another thing that I
hate so according to San Francisco they
are now registering non-citizens
including undocumented immigrants to
register to vote in the November
election for the city school board
according to the San Francisco Chronicle
the move follows passage of a 2016
ballot measure by San Francisco voters
opening school elections to non-citizens
who are over the age of 18 hillary ronan
who's a san francisco supervisor said
this is no-brainer legislation why would
we not want our parents invested in the
education of their children now I'm fine
with parents being invested in the
education of their children I'm just not
fine with parents who don't pay taxes
being invested in how tax dollars get
spent at the public school it seems to
me that you ought to be in the system
and if you don't pay taxes because you
don't have to under the law that's one
thing but why shouldn't I mean you could
literally make this argument by any any
criminal in United States any criminal
you could say somebody who was convicted
of predatory child sex abuse they should
be able to vote in local elections if
they have a kid right now undocumented
immigration illegal immigration is not
the same thing obviously as pedophilia
but the point is is a general legal one
which is that if law breaking is not a
barrier to voting then why shouldn't we
have any law breaker who has a kid able
to vote in school watches maybe they
would say that you should maybe they
would say that you should I don't know
the San Francisco they're real weird
over there and they poop on the sidewalk
so it's quite a possibility but that
said is this a good model probably not
and what you will see and it'll be
hilarious is a bunch of people who don't
pay taxes voting for more and more tax
spending which will eventually allow for
people to move out of the school
district when the school district is
bankrupted by all the people who are
voting for more benefits to which they
do not pay in okay we'll be back here
tomorrow with all the latest i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018